a primera vista una clase cotidiana pero
en realidad estos alumnos siguen un plan
de estudios inédito hasta ahora en
Italia un curso experimental dedicado a
la transición digital y ecológica el
objetivo educar a los alumnos sobre los
retos medioambientales del mañana aquí
la clase estudia una nueva aplicación en
particular
pues aplicaciones esta app está hecha
para controlar el despilfarro de
alimentos y para mostrarnos lo que
ahorraríamos si dejáramos de
despilfarrar
Durante las próximas semanas cada alumno
tendrá que probar la app para ayudar a
los desarrolladores del Software vamos a
poner todo lo que desperdiciaste anoche
en la cena en casa tiramos unos 10
gramos de pan entonces aquí está el
coste Y cuánto CO2 Se generó
el programa se basa en los 17 objetivos
de desarrollo sostenible de la agenda
2030 de Naciones Unidas hemos estudiado
en particular la gestión del agua las
energías alternativas y la lucha entre
el hambre en el mundo
la lección continúa fuera del aula en un
campo de Olivos a unos 100 kilómetros al
norte de Roma un agrónomo les muestra
los métodos de cultivo sostenible
utilizados in situ fuiste miren esto es
una trampa para insectos es una idea
nueva para atrapar la mosca que ataca a
los olivos hace 15 años pulverizábamos
insecticida por todas partes Incluso en
los olivos esta trampa solo atrae a las
moscas macho gracias a las feromonas
femeninas y eso impide que se
reproduzcan
estos estudiantes tienen que conocer las
nuevas tecnologías implicadas en el
desarrollo sostenible para entender Qué
opciones profesionales existen en este
nuevo mundo agrícola
todo mundo agrícola
de momento 27 escuelas participan en el
proyecto piloto aquí en Italia